[Music]
on this thursday night stalemate in the
nation's capital
as protesters vow to stay put demands
for answers grow who is funding the
protest and who's responsible for
enforcing the law one has to be very
very cautious before
deploying
military also tonight who's lining up to
lead the federal tories no that's not of
any interest to me a look at who's
ruling themselves out and who might be
in the running to replace aaron o'toole
no i have my hands full plus
saskatchewan's premiere signals the end
of the road for covid19 restrictions
what's necessary is your freedom
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are starting again in the nation's
capital tonight and the disruption
caused by that noisy protest near
parliament hill
the so-called freedom convoy that's
restricting freedoms for those who live
and work in downtown ottawa organizers
who ottawa police say are getting
funding and organizational help from the
united states are refusing to budge
ottawa's police chief under pressure to
act has said there may not be a policing
solution
and today the defense minister tweeted
this the canadian forces are not a
police force there are no plans for the
canadian armed forces to be involved in
the current situation in ottawa in a law
enforcement capacity
well pressure is mounting for someone in
authority to enforce the law and clear
the protest and now go fund me the
platform used to raise more than 10
million dollars for protesters is being
called to testify before a parliamentary
committee about where the money is going
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
it's become double-barreled gridlock the
downtown core of ottawa paralyzed by a
small group shutting down ordinary life
and business and the decision-making on
what to do about it seemingly frozen in
place the military could end it but the
prime minister says that's not an option
not right now it is not something uh
that anyone should enter in likely uh
lightly uh but uh as of now there have
been no uh requests and uh and that is
not uh in the cards right now yet ottawa
police have made clear they don't see
police action as an option either there
is likely no policing solutions the fear
is that a relatively stable
demonstration could become volatile you
don't want to escalate it
you know the
focus has to be keep the peace but how
then does it end a chief organizer for
the truckers says they're not leaving
our departure will be based on the prime
minister doing what is right
ending all mandates and restrictions on
our freedoms tamara leach is a central
figure in the standoff she began a
gofundme campaign for the trucker convoy
for fuel and food that's raised more
than 10 million dollars but there are
questions whether the money's coming
from outside the country gofundme has
blocked the fundraiser stating it's
currently paused and under review to
ensure it complies with our terms of
service and applicable laws
leach now has a legal team trying to
release the millions of dollars there's
audit procedures and so on in place
which will allow gofundme to flow the
funds though when questions were asked
about possible american contributions
the news conference was cut off i'm glad
to have you come out today
the other organizer named on the
gofundme page was well received on fox
news describing canada's government in
disturbing terms justin trudeau's
promises of sunny ways
into dark authoritarian oppression and
control why is it fun to you to connect
the obvious dots god bless you for that
there are extreme elements in the ottawa
protests and huge fundraising raises
alarms for some where is this money
going are we okay if one million goes to
causes
uh that we find out of the realm of what
is socially acceptable in 2022. today
the commons committee on public safety
and national security met mr mckinnon
uh yes
mr noah muhammad yes and they voted
unanimously to have the gofundme website
testify about its safeguards in
releasing close to 10 million dollars
for the trucker convoy eric sorenson
global news toronto
now to developments in southern alberta
and that protest blocking a busy border
crossing traffic is moving again but the
situation is not fully resolved
protesters say they'll resume the
blockade unless all coveted related
public health restrictions are lifted
and now alberta's premier appears to be
bowing to that pressure heather urex
west reports
after nearly a week of disruption and
delay the canada u.s border crossing at
kutz alberta is open to traffic again
relief i can work i got bills to pay on
the fifth day of an illegal border
blockade protesters agreed to move their
vehicles late wednesday afternoon that's
not to say that the situation isn't
tenuous and that things can't
disintegrate
very fast but as long as the parties are
giving on both ends of the spectrum and
as long as voices are being heard
still protesters plan to remain until
all federal vaccine mandates and
provincial coveted restrictions are
lifted with rcmp limiting access to the
community protest supporters also
continue to gather beyond a police
checkpoint near the community of milk
river this is very important
you know we have to
let the world know
that this is
very like the mass the vaccine mandates
you can't force that on people that are
religiously not able to do that
according to the premier alberta's
restrictions could be lifted soon on
wednesday night jason kenney said on
social media i get the frustration out
there but the end of covett restrictions
is near please stay tuned in the coming
days for more information med alberta's
government has no jurisdiction over the
federal or u.s coveted policies that
require truckers traveling across the
border get the vaccine
something the vast majority of truckers
have already done i just need to work so
i understand what they're doing you know
i get it but for the ones that need to
work
you guys carry on protesting peacefully
just let us go through
and at this rcmp checkpoint north of
coos traffic does appear to still be
getting through but with uh the
southbound lanes jammed with a line of
protesters going back more than a
kilometer there are significant delays
so while the border blockade may be over
for now
things are far from back to normal here
in southern alberta donna
okay heather yurix west near milk river
alberta tonight thank you
a conservative mp who is a staunch
supporter of the trucker protest has
been chosen as the interim leader of the
federal party
candice bergen was welcomed in her new
role in the house of commons today the
manitoba mp was chosen by her caucus
last night after the majority of tory
mps voted to get rid of aaron o'toole
bergen's time at the top will be
temporary though while the tories
launched their third leadership race in
six years who will step up to take
control of the fractured party is a hot
topic of debate our senior political
correspondent david aiken has been
talking to senior tories david well
donna at this point it's probably easier
to start off with a list of who is not
running let's start with the premier of
alberta
no i am so completely focused on these
incredibly huge challenges we're facing
right now that's uh that's not of any
interest to me the premier of ontario no
i have my hands full i love being
premier of this province some are
pushing patrick brown the former ontario
pc leader and current mayor of brampton
were you right
my only focus right now is getting
brampton reopened brad wall has said no
same with peter mckay rana ambrose and
lisa raitt but rate who ran for leader
in 2017 knows what she wants in a new
leader so gender doesn't matter
i think the only must-have is french
other than that what i'm looking for is
somebody who is going to be respected in
whatever field they're in politics
business law whatever it is as long as
they have the respect of their peers
that they can speak convincingly and
they are able to have people follow them
right now the buzz in conservative
circles is all about pierre paliev he's
a former harper cabinet minister who is
tremendously popular with the grassroots
and with caucus he's also one of the
party's best draws in terms of
fundraising but so far he is not saying
anything about leadership same with
leslie lewis the ontario mp who ran in
2019 and finished third another ontario
mp marilyn gladu wanted to run last time
but ran into fundraising problems she's
thinking of trying again i think this is
a chance for a fresh start a chance to
unify and
rebuild no one is expected to announce
that they're running though until the
party sets the rules rules that will not
be set for several weeks but which will
be crucial in shaping the race a long
campaign for example might attract
people from outside politics in fact
some influential conservatives have been
encouraging mark mulroney to run he's a
bay street banker and the 42 year old
son of the former pm brian mulroney but
a short race with a high entry fee would
definitely favor insider candidates with
their own fundraising network candidates
like pierre pauliev donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
the u.s president says american special
forces have carried out an overnight
raid in syria that killed the new leader
of the so-called islamic state it
happened in northwestern syria in a
border town near turkey first responders
on the ground say at least 13 people
were killed including six children and
four women
jackson proskow is with me from
washington now jackson what more do we
know about this operation
well donna this operation was months in
the planning and in many ways mirrors
the operation that killed osama bin
laden u.s special forces troops were
sent in by helicopter for the pre-dawn
raid the pentagon says one of those
helicopters suffered a mechanical
failure and had to be destroyed in the
field speaking to the nation president
biden says he chose to send in troops
over air strikes to avoid civilian
casualties but as u.s forces moved in
the pentagon says abu ibrahim al-hashimi
al-qarashi detonated a bomb that killed
him and members of his own family
including several children
in a final act of desperate
cowardness
he with no regard to the lives of his
own family or others in the building he
chose to blow himself up not just to the
vest but to blow up that third floor
rather than face justice for the crimes
he has committed
jackson al-qarashi kept a lower profile
than the previous leader of isis what do
we know about him
well donna the 45 year old was believed
to be attempting to rebuild the
so-called islamic state following the
death of his predecessor the group had
started to see a resurgence in places
like syria iraq and lebanon while the
white house insists this strike has
delivered a major blow to the
organization it's worth noting that
there are still cells and sympathizers
of isis out there they're still in
existence donna
okay jackson prosco in washington thanks
now to the tension over ukraine tonight
we're taking you to a part of eastern
europe that is usually quiet but there
are some warning signs now that could
change it's where ukraine belarus and
russia meet border crossings are open
and it is business as usual
still belarus and russia have been
conducting military exercise and that's
making ukraine and the west nervous our
europe bureau chief crystal gamansing
traveled to the area just past the
ukraine border
right now i am standing on neutral
territory behind the camera is ukraine
over to this side is russia and belarus
is that way the monument behind me is
the three sisters monument a sign of the
friendship of the unification of this
area of course that's not the situation
right now
we structures special forces people like
who control the territory and if
something happen they will be
arrive here as soon as possible
while state border officer alexandra
stupak says they haven't seen an
increase in activity here military
intelligence provides a different view
as many as 30 000 russian forces could
be taking part in military drills on the
belarussian side of the border this is
the biggest russian deployment there
since the cold war
still the three-way border remains open
truckers who have driven the route say
they've seen nothing no zero
zero the hope is that it stays that way
the northern front is peaceful unlike
the donbass region in the east
fighting there has been ongoing since
2014 when russian-backed separatists
captured large areas in the region after
russia annexed crimea
the east appears to be where most
ukrainian soldiers are being deployed
but units are on the move on our drive
north from kiev we passed one convoy
in nearby horradia a russian invasion is
inconceivable
i don't believe how this could happen
because i have my sister there who is
living there and i have my nephews who
is also living there i kinda
understand how this could happen because
we are relatives still some people here
tell global news they'd pick up arms to
defend ukraine
and we will see only god knows
how it will be for now the shops are
open and trucks are crossing the border
those who patrol here know peace in this
vast multinational intersection could be
disrupted in an instant crystal
commansing global news
senkica ukraine
planning to live with covid19 coming up
why experts are urging caution as some
regions move to lift all restrictions
[Music]
saskatchewan's premier intends to remove
all coveted public health restrictions
in the coming days scott mo made the
announcement in a late night social
media post yesterday he's not acting on
scientific advice but on what he's
hearing from constituents
may continue to see covet morph into
different variants and forms in the
coming months and years
but we need to end the perpetual state
of crisis what's necessary is your
freedom what's necessary is getting your
life back to normal
the premier says his province will
manage kovig much like other
communicable diseases it is a shift some
jurisdictions around the world have
already made as jamie morocco reports
experts warn against moving too fast
the grill at this saskatoon restaurant
might be hot but thanks to kovid
business has cooled people they don't
feel very safe to go out
and that's why the business is slow two
years of staying home masking social
distancing and then vaccinating to tamp
coveted spread has left many canadians
desperate for anything normal
and the idea of living with this
coronavirus is no longer novel moving
forward we'll be treating covert the way
we treat uh say the seasonal flu or
other respiratory viruses that
that are circulating within the
community annual vaccines and common
sense hand washing and staying home when
sick will be our safety nets as experts
move away from recommending stringent
restrictions a new study out of johns
hopkins university suggests pandemic
lockdowns were not effective at reducing
mortality rates globally and a growing
list of countries are already opening up
most recently denmark and sweden they're
in a completely different situation than
we are regarding icus their icu numbers
are actually going down
a key indicator in making the move to
return to normal although
hospitalization numbers in ontario and
quebec appear to have plateaued across
western canada they are still rising
manitoba bc and saskatchewan with record
numbers this week the burden is largely
saddled from those reopening plans when
they don't go so well on the frontline
healthcare system making timing critical
and specific to each province if we see
another surge
then we've taken the wrong decision or
somebody wasn't listening to the to the
evidence as it was going in
let's treat it carefully and cautiously
with the goal of a springer summer with
fewer masks and mandates but new
variants remain a variable too jamie
morocco global news toronto
cash cow ahead what's causing canadian
dairy prices to spike
if you've noticed you have been paying
more for dairy products you're not alone
this week there was a steep increase
part of the reason is that dairy farmers
are now getting paid more for the milk
they produce but that is not the only
factor driving up prices and as ann
gaviola explains there is more sticker
shock in store
the pandemic has thrown dairy farmers
one curveball after another to help them
out the dairy commission this fall
announced an 8.4 increase in the price
paid to milk producers the biggest
annual jump ever nearly double the
largest previous increase this hike took
effect on tuesday and it's already
hitting consumers at the till and it's
yet another blow to struggling
restaurants it's going to hurt a lot
global news compared 4-liter canadian
milk prices this week against their
january costs in halifax it's up 8.6 in
some spots prices at some toronto stores
jumped nearly 15 percent and in parts of
calgary and across bc the price soared
nearly 16
multiple requests for comment from
loblaw longos walmart and sobeys were
ignored a spokesperson for metro which
also owns food basics said metro does
not comment on future pricing or pricing
strategies
in an email to global news the canadian
dairy commission says higher input costs
such as feed and fuel required this bump
in price farmers must be able to meet
their expenses and pay local suppliers
and employees sadly and really really
unfortunately we may see restaurants
local coffee shops close because of that
restaurants canada says this could be a
knockout punch especially for pizza
places and coffee shops which rely
heavily on dairy
and canadian households will have to pay
more or choose milk and cheese
alternatives too if families start being
unable to provide milk to their kids or
they start rationing it or diluting it
you're going to start to see an increase
in health concerns
according to research from dalhousie
university the average family of four
can expect to pay an additional two
hundred dollars in dairy groceries this
year and that's on top of the rising
cost of just about everything donna
and gaviola in toronto thanks
from the soccer field to olympic ice
next the canadians dominating the world
of sports
canada's men's soccer team has continued
its impressive push towards the world
cup with a two-nothing win over el
salvador the game included a bizarre
goal from captain atiba hutchinson
helping the team capture its sixth
straight victory canada can officially
clinch a spot in the world cup during
their next games in march
the opening ceremonies are tomorrow but
the winter games are already underway in
beijing and team canada is crushing it
the women's hockey team steamrolled
switzerland in their first match winning
twelve to one did come at a cost though
veteran canadian forward melanie daou
was forced to leave the game because of
an injury it's unclear if she'll be back
for the next game against finland
and canada and curling of course go hand
in hand the mixed doubles team had their
first win at the beijing games ottawa's
rachel homan and john morris beat norway
7-6 their next match-up will be tough
they play the silver medalists from the
last games switzerland
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this beautiful shot from
powell river bc there are beautiful
spots all over canada please email us
yours to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you